petit talon
leurs activités ou bien garçon je ne me
pose même pas la question du t'appellera
nicole et pas de discussion
teva l'eau
il y aura une rose à ton prénom
tu seras là plus joli bébé
de me lire et demi
avec des cheveux courts vêtu en aura
les yeux bleus
je paie
chacun va c'est nous
j'avais
brassée dans ton
petit
mais j'ai trop court du lombez de jour
en jour du fait l'admiration des profs
en ont des goûts
tu
aurais
dû aux gens qu aucun
tuchan jourdain
photo maguy lancashire fumet des hauts
talons ou encore un peu tu dépasses ce
pas mr
c'était pas très malin les filles des
filles font toujours la chouette
l'emploi passe nicole l'école
le temps
tu l'as déjà plein
pour un bien
je n'ai pas eu le temps passe et voit la
vie en vert te voilà marielle tu quittes
la maison pour un qui te donne
bon ben
déjà quasi
gel à ses rangs dont l'idh
je t'aime
jacob a su nous
j'avais